he's on shameless yeah oh he's the guy
that sleeps with the Steve's never stop
working I gotta get him on the podcast
he's never stopped working he's amazing
anyway he's married been married a long
time what is he doing with his hands in
his pants right here being cautious be
invisible hot gets men no no no but so
so so check this out so we're at the
improv and his wife he's been married a
long time
these dudes rough-looking guys kind of
good-looking table guys like maybe four
dudes maybe five guys but they're
they're big they're athletic guys yeah
and one guy just keeps looking back
obviously the kind of guy who's used to
getting female attention and he keeps
looking back at Steve's wife and and
he's giving her the he's being a little
disrespectful he's giving her the up and
down and steve steevo old lion head he's
wearing an argyle sweater vest - right
and Steve Steve looks at the guy and he
goes and then the guy says something to
his wife no no like like Steve goes
Steve goes kidding me this [ __ ] guy
something like that oh and the guy
doesn't hear and I and I clock all this
I gotta go onstage and then the guy says
something like were you from - the girl
- his wife oh and Steve goes hey bro you
[ __ ] stupid or something she's with
me and the guy goes you had a [ __ ]
problem
and Steve stands up and the guy stands
up and Steve again is bigger but he's
with these other dudes and they take
notice they're big and I and Steve is
doing this Steve is literally standing
there like this and he starts going and
moving his tongue back and forth he's
never even back and forth like a cobra
he's going like this and you can see
that it before guys gonna beat him up
but somebody's gonna lose an eye
somebody's gonna lose and somebody's
gonna be putting a can cut like in a cop
because he's just too big he's the kind
of guy that can clearly take a shitload
of punishment you know he's just and
he's crazy enough and he's definitely
gonna fight yeah so he's doing this
weird Cobra thing I and I see disaster
and I got to go up on stage and these
guys are scary though and I also know
that these guys are athletic and they're
not hearing a peep out of them either
and there
so I grabbed the dude and I go like this
I go hey guys guys guys guys you see who
is that the guy that you're about to
fight he is a homicide detective and
he's with the LAPD and all his buddies
are outside at the bar and they can't
wait to arrest you and they're all as
big as he is so if you guys want to
fight a cop a homicide detective please
do so but please know also you'll be
cuffed you'll be black and blue and you
will spend the next five days in jail I
promise you that's my promise to all of
you right away yeah and they sat the
[ __ ] down they apologized I have a
question yeah I have a question yes but
that whole situation could have been
diverted no I know how all right so
let's take awhile that's right here at
salado's right here right you're the guy
say something to kalila were you from
and this is me yeah hey oh she was no I
would have oh and you would have just
jumped in and go not me guys no you
can't have me I'm just saying this girl
Lila's not I already know the colliders
not gonna [ __ ] this dude yeah unless he
rapes her right bananas name kalila okay
you met her before that's ignore me I've
worked with yeah you worked with her
before but um anyway he's not gonna rape
her right then and there or take her out
she's not gonna hook up with him so
what's gonna happen so I just go I would
just go hi ya know what standing up
there's no lies going on with you saying
hi you saying hi is not really that
interesting to that guy he's a wolf
yeah look all you know what this is
[ __ ] what you're saying to me right
now this [ __ ] predator [ __ ] alpha
male [ __ ] hey you and Joe Rogan and
all these guys do you I'm a survivor too
okay
yeah I'm a gatherer you're a guy yes
Cokely I'll do it differently sticks a
new buyer here a little battle my point
is I'm gonna eat the deer me too no
you're not and you have clogged you'll
be waiting with my food and I want your
button here and I'll do that too
we gotta live well we all survived
currently here's how I do it yeah you
said something with that story early
when when if I get into a little bit of
trouble I start like if I'm really mad
I'll just I'll take the person on even
if they're as big as Steve yeah because
I might be dead I probably would be but
he'd be blind not with oh you be blind
I take them and let's get them off I so
believe Andy yes I know that you're in
trouble
yes got your eyes on I've seen you drunk
and I've seen your energy like you have
a crazy amount of energy like where
you're you're moving at such a pace
where you would be such a handful to
fight horrible yeah yeah why are you
what are you Irish don't know I think a
little bit yeah you're you're such a
nose adopted because you talk like
you're kind of like you talk a bit
feminine yeah yeah but you're also like
you also have three kids and you're also
you're complicated you're sevens you're
sexually complicated okay you're
sexually complement you're a comedic
genius and you're also but you're also
kind of a hunter and a killer yeah oh
yeah well he's everything do it look you
are when you see my back ripple and I
pull myself up like a champ like a chimp
230 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift